[Music]
I remember a few weeks ago we talked
about this you ever know about doggy G
no Tommy DeVos no kind of like a
legendary hacker okay listen to a little
podcast about him okay tell me about it
fun guy fun guy okay so he kind of
started his hacking career
by just hanging out on IRC okay and
wanting to know more about hacking okay
so it started with him and kind of brute
forcing his way socially into a group
and then they made him part of this
group
of hackers where they would take over
IRC channels okay
so I was like you know
fun kind of kids yeah I think they're uh
their hacker group was like TFK or
something and it stood for those [__]
kids okay
um and then they evolved into defacing
websites okay so he's done them all you
know like Alta Vista Yahoo whatever
so then
I think
because he I forgot what of these but he
defaced something and he basically got
arrested oh no yeah was it the FBI no no
he [__]
he issued a fake
threat onto his school okay he like
hacked like a Korean military's
General's email okay they sent an email
to his school saying like you know
uh we're taking action whatever we're
gonna what destroy just this once yeah
yeah whatever and it was like a small I
think he grew up in a small town so
naturally they're kind of like go [__]
okay and he just did that because he
didn't want to be in school right he
just wanted to go like hang out with his
boys and so he got caught
and
I think he was put on probation he
basically did a couple prison stints
and conditions of his probation every
time were
um
he you can't use a computer
and he kind of like really struggled
with that because it's kind of all he
knew he was young
uh there was a point in time where he
was on probation and what he used to do
was he had a computer I would imagine
like an open case and
um if you ever saw his parole officer
pulling up he would dismantle the PC put
different parts
like uh surrounding like his room okay
uh he did this one time and he forgot to
put the keyboard away okay oh the P
outside and he went back in he got back
out
and he set up his computer so that now
uh he could see out a window but whoever
was driving up couldn't see into his
window okay
and uh some [__] FBI agents I guess
his parents needed to sell their home so
some FBI agents came posing as like
people interested in purchasing away I
saw him in the room on the computer
so they came back with a warrant and
they took and then I think that was the
one that put him away for a while okay
and
was he hacking while he was on Parole
yeah I mean he's just you know he's just
you know [__] around with his friends
and there there's this uh person that
commented on the podcast saying he's so
[__] pathetic he doesn't even realize
it and that's obviously a young person
talking [__] and I was thinking they
don't understand in his era probably one
like dude
it's really funny anyone from gen Z like
criticizing someone like this it's like
dude you couldn't stay off your phone
for a [__] week yeah yeah yeah like
yeah and there there was nothing to
[__] do back then yeah I know and
this was like when the internet was like
an entirely separate world yeah it's
like it was like when if VR ever
actually becomes a thing yeah you go
home and you log on to VR that's why it
was like like you log on to IRC and you
could like chat live with your friends
without like anyone looking over your
shoulder like it was the most magic
thing possible so we're like vlogging on
to video games or whatever yeah the best
so
he goes away and he does some time
um and in prison you know he accumulated
a bunch of tats like gotten the [__]
and he gets out and so the crazy part is
he
is now he's clean and now he hears
yeah well it clean like his records
clean okay like you know he's done his
time yeah yeah because he kind of kept
going in and out for the same charge
yeah he kept breaking parole I think
so then he
discovers or or so now we're at the
point where Tech has kind of grown and
now they're doing the bug bounties
so he sees one for 150 bucks he needs
money and every every time he goes to
apply for work he can't get a job
even uh I think even applied to a bank
at some point and he had a really good
resume but because of his Federal record
they were basically thinking that he
might go in and steal money okay so they
they're like oh sorry can't move forward
yeah so he sees these bug bounties
and that's kind of his uh like his means
now where he takes down these crazy bug
bounties and what's Wild
is he as I think he initially went to
prison for defacing Yahoo's like website
and now he's getting paid from them
to basically hack their [__] and figure
out
you know or I don't think Yahoo exists
anymore but that was like one of his bug
bounties so it's like it came full
circle
but it begs the question like
was arresting him even necessary like
was that just like some Boomer crony
thing where they're like you're a bad
child
um is this guy famous yeah doggy G Tommy
DeVos look him up
these are his bug bounties
how much has he made he's made a [__]
ton of money he did he had a bug Bounty
where he what does that say
so that one bug he was paid out ten
thousand dollars for but that was
disclosed five years ago a lot of times
the bounties aren't disclosed publicly
yeah he said he did one he did one bug
Bounty and he from a single Bounty he
made a hundred fifty thousand dollars oh
my God yeah and what is he doing is he
fixing bugs or is he hacking their
systems from the outside yeah he's
hacking from the outside and so but I
think they're putting up like bug
reports like Hey we're having this issue
if someone can figure it out yeah right
can't figure it out and so he's just
sitting there doing like reverse
engineering and so he
um the podcast is really interesting
because by the end of it
he's basically saying yeah like I yeah
this is the what's this channel uh uh
Jack Risner it's just the Dark Knight
Diaries podcast yeah Dark Net Diaries
who else is he interview I don't know I
was gonna go through some more but this
one was pretty good
um
this I'm already compelled by this yeah
it's like underground internet [__] yeah
yeah hackers you know black hat
this is always cool
you know I was thinking would be a great
scam um
just while we're talking about hacking
and stealing and [__] like that fake
parking tickets yeah
it'd be so easy so [__] easy you know
how like with this like a pay with this
QR code yeah like hey you got tagged for
this and then the websites are always
like LA City Dash parking dot yeah Co
yeah and you're like what the [__] is
this and you go to it and it's like
barely a government website yeah like
the government contracted some stupid
developer to make this oh it looked
horrible always it always looks like a
scam yeah why not just make your own and
then just leave the parking tickets
around those payment flows are like
weird old like PHP pages I know where
it's just a form and you just send card
info in yeah yeah oh California team
made fake parking tickets in this candle
collect payments please yeah
no way someone did it yeah arrested a 19
year old they say made fake parking
tickets and put them on parked cars near
the beach the fake tickets had a QR code
that victims could scan to pay the
fraudulent citations yeah
yeah
how do you get caught
probably a [__] ton bro you think so
probably so many people probably fall
for that and so many people just pay
them without thinking if barely if you
get a couple people each ticket's like
eighty dollars like yeah
I bet he got caught because you like put
something stupid on the like
what it has to have a reason for it you
know I I shitty car
shitty car I bet you just don't sucks
ass wall you probably just dumped a
ticket on like a city person or an
actual parking
person pulled up and was like the [__]
is this yeah probably and then you know
they just traced the purchase he's like
oh I'm sorry they called me today to do
I they didn't tell you I'm taking your
shift today yeah
yeah I'm good man I got it yeah get out
of here is that him Thomas DeVos oh
that's the doggy G yeah oh so you got a
regular job
so that was I think one of the most
interesting things he said was
as much as bug bounties paid really well
he
uh was really
really craving a legitimate job yeah
um because
one his father just for the longest time
just
look down on him you know uh didn't
respect them and he didn't View
all the knowledge he was accruing as a
hacker is like useful or horrible or
whatever
um
and so he was like when he applied for
that bank job I think I believe he said
he was kind of crushed because he was
hoping that that would have opened the
door for him and his father to like
actually have a relationship again and
above everything
uh he really wanted like a regular nine
to five he also said that bug bounties
was just really depressing because
he could do it in a pretty short amount
of time and he's accruing like large
sums of cash so he can take a lot of
time off he said there's only so much
Xbox I can play before I'm like craving
social interaction hmm
well not disagree with that but maybe
yeah yeah no that's no it's totally fair
yeah I think I think he just you know he
strikes me as one of those dudes that
didn't know he was good at something
and he realized it very late in life so
now it's like oh [__] yeah
you know now what yeah but yeah it was
also really really interesting part
where he was
um he knew he was going to go to prison
in like two weeks and so for two weeks
he was just going ham uh he has he
actually has a massive interest in cars
he owns a lot of skylines which is
really sick and so he's like for two
weeks I was just street racing partying
every night trying to sleep with as many
girls as possible because I knew I'm
going away for a long time yeah I'm like
that's pretty hard yeah that is pretty
sick
just all out just because two weeks yeah
just because he put dicks on yahoo.com
yeah so petty yeah